YOU JUST LEARNED NEW INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FATE OF THE SHOW?
>> TLC STAYING QUIET NOW SAY
TAKING THE SHOW OFF THE AIR
SAYING THEIR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS ARE WITH THE FAMILY AND
THE VICTIMS IN THE CASE CALLING
IT A VERY DIFFICULT TIME.
THIS TIME IS NOT OVER YET.
THIS SITUATION REALLY IS A
FAMILY IN CRISIS, DISCOVERY AND
TLC, NO TIME FOR A TELEVISION
SHOW.
♪ LIFT UP YOUR EYES ♪
AND SEE ♪
>> Reporter: FOR YEARS THE
DUGGARS HAVE BEEN TLC'S BIGGEST
FAMILY, BANKING ON AN IMAGE OF
WHOLESOME CHRISTIAN VALUING.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO USE THE
BIBLE.
>> Reporter: THAT HAVE GAINED
THEM THE FAVOR OF HIGH-PROFILE
CONSERVATIVES AND APPEARED
ALONGSIDE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES.
>> STANDING FOR YOUR VALUES.
>> Reporter: NOW A DISTURBING
REVELATION ABOUT THE DUGGARS
ELDEST SON JOSH COULD DEEP RAIL
EVERYTHING.
A REPORT BY "IN-TOUCH" WEEKLY
ALLEGING HE MOLESTED SEVERAL
YOUNG GIRLS INCLUDING FAMILY
MEMBER.
JOSH APOLOGIZED IN A STATEMENT
ON HIS FAMILY'S FACEBOOK PAGE
WRITING, 12 YEARS AGO, I ACTED
INEXCUSABLY FOR WHICH I'M
EXTREMELY SORRY AND DEEPLY
REGRET.
WE SPOKE WITH AUTHORITIES WHERE
I CONFESSED BY WRONGDOING.
IN THE SAME STATEMENT JOSH'S
PARENTS ADMIT THEY'VE KNOWN
ABOUT HIS ACTIONS FOR YEARS
ADDING WE PRAY AS PEOPLE WATCH
OUR LIVES THEY SEE WE ARE NOT A
PERFECT FAMILY.
>> YOU WOULD THINK IT'S, YOU
KNOW, PAST MEMORY.
THIS IS CHILD MOLESTATION'S THIS
IS A FAMILY VALUE SHOW.
I JUST DON'T SEE HOW IT
SURVIVES.
>> Reporter: WITH CAMERA CREWS
AND PRODUCERS WATCHING THE
FAMILY CITIZENS 2008, CRITICS
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT TLC HAS
ALSO KEPT THIS STORY UNDER
WRAPS.
>> THE WHOLE FOUNDATION IS ABOUT
FAMILY VALUES.
AT LEAST THAT'S HOW I FRAME IT.
IT'S ABOUT RAISING A FAMILY,
ABOUT PROTECTING CHILDREN.
RAISING CHILDREN IN THE RIGHT
WAY.
AND THIS ADMISSION GOES AGAINST
EVERYTHING THAT THEY TALK ABOUT.
>> Reporter: TMZ REPORTS THE
OPRAH WINFREY SHOW WAS TIPPED
OFF TO JOSH'S ACTIONS IN 2006,
PRIOR TO AN INTERVIEW.
PRODUCERS REPORTEDLY CANCELLED
THE SEGMENT AND NOTIFIED A CHILD
PROTECTION HOT LINE.
CNN HAS CONTACTED OPRAH'S
NETWORK, BUT SO FAR THEY ARE
SAYING NOTHING.
MEANTIME, JOSH'S RESIGNED FROM
HIS PROMINENT ROLE WITH THE
FAMILY RESEARCH COUNCIL.
A WELL-KNOWN CONSERVATIVE
CHRISTIAN GROUP IN WASHINGTON.
BUT AT LEAST ONE HIGH-PROFILE
FRIEND IS STICKING BY THE
DUGGARS.
>> DEAR FRIENDS, WONDERFUL AND
AN EXEMPLARY FAMILY.
>> Reporter: APPEARING WITH THE
DUGGARS LAST MONTH AND IN A
STATEMENT HUCKABEE CONFIRMED
CONTINUED SUPPORT WRITING GOOD
PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKE AND DO
REGRETTABLE AND EVEN DISGUSTING
THINGS.
LET OTHERS RUN FROM THEM.
WE WILL RUN TO THEM WITH OUR
SUPPORT.
>> MOST THINGS ARE FORGIVABLE IN
THE AMERICAN CONSCIENCE.
CHILD MOLESTATION IS JUST NOT.
>> USUALLY GOOD PUBLICITY.
A RARE CASE WHERE IT'S NOT TRUE.
THE PROGRAM'S NOT BEING